tief medizin an der universität des
saarlandes und vielen sicherlich auch
bekannt als arzt der deutschen
fußballnationalmannschaft uns
zugeschaltet ist frau professor dr
barbara gärtner frau professor gärtner
ist ebenfalls mitglied der taskforce
sportmedizin sonder spielbetrieb
gleichzeitig fachärztin für
mikrobiologie und
infektionsepidemiologie an der
universität des saarlandes gleichzeitig
ist folgt gärtner langjährige beraterin
des deutschen olympischen sportbundes
infektions fragen vorab der hinweis alle
informationen die wir ihnen heute
präsentieren erhalten sie
selbstverständlich nach der
pressekonferenz online auf der welt de
meine damen und herren herr seifert ich
darf ihnen das wort geben bitte
vielen dank herr fällig guten tag ich
hatte nach der letzten
mitgliederversammlung darauf hingewiesen
dass wir uns intensiv damit befassen wie
der neustart der bundesliga und zweiten
bundesliga gelingen könnte und wie diese
aussehen wird
nach wie vor gilt dass es in einer
solchen für uns alle ja noch nie
dagewesenen situation nicht nur einen
definitiven plan gibt sondern dass
zwangsläufig jeder plan den man hat von
vornherein flexibel angelegt sein muss
und es muss aber irgend eine
strategische idee geben und das gilt in
diesen tagen sicherlich nicht nur für
die bundesliga sondern auch für tausende
von unternehmen selbstständigen
öffentlichen institutionen und auch
privathaushalte irgendwann muss es
weiter gehen und irgendwann wird es
weitergehen auch wenn das noch für
längere zeit nur in kleinen schritten
sein wird wofür wir alle verständnis
haben müssen und sicherlich auch haben
wann dieser zeitpunkt für die zweite
bundesliga und für die bundesliga
gekommen sein könnte daraus darüber gab
es in den letzten tagen einige aussagen
und viele spekulationen für uns bleibt
einzigen allein entscheidend was die
politisch verantwortlichen beschließen
und deshalb liegt es auch nicht an uns
einen starttermin der bundesliga
festzulegen ich habe schon beim letzten
mal gesagt wenn der tag ist da sein wird
dann werden wir bereit sein und falls
die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung entscheiden
dass dieser tag der neunte mai wäre dann
werden wir am 9 mai bereit sein tag
danach sein sollte dann werden wir
bereit sein
lassen sie mich nochmals betonen ob der
neubau oder ein späterer zeitpunkt dass
wir wieder spielen können ist für einige
klubs die wirtschaftliche rettung aber
spiele ohne zuschauer werden anders
aussehen sie werden sich anders anfühlen
sie werden auch sie werden sich auch
anders anhören und ich möchte die hier
auch nicht schöner darstellen als sie
sind für den moment sind sie aber nun
mal die einzige möglichkeit die
bundesliga und zweite bundesliga wie wir
sie kennen aus den letzten jahrzehnten
und auch wie sich sehr viele menschen
etwas bedeutet am leben zu erhalten und
ich bitte heute schon alle wirklich alle
die sich für die bundesliga
interessieren ob mehr oder weniger dafür
um nachsicht und um unterstützung spiele
ohne zuschauer ist nicht das was wir
wollen
aber es ist für den moment das einzige
was machbar scheint bevor ich zu den
ergebnissen der sitzungen komme lassen
sie vielleicht noch eine kurze anmerkung
machen ich sitze heute hier nicht auch
gemeinsam mit frau professor gärtnern
herrn professor meyer um in jeden etwas
zu verkaufen oder für irgendetwas zu
werben ich sitze heute hier als
vertreter eines unternehmens das
zurückkehren möchte und früher oder
später wie viele andere auch wieder
zurückkehren muss zur arbeit
und um das produkt profifußball
herzustellen braucht es nun mal gewisse
und sehr sehr spezielle
rahmenbedingungen und um das unter
diesen umständen tun zu können wo wir
nach wie vor mit der korona krise zu
kämpfen haben
braucht es deshalb auch spezifischer und
spezieller vorbereitung denn das kann
man drehen und wenden wie man will wir
werden auf einem spielfeld nicht ein
meter fünfzig abstand halten können um
einfach nur mal ein beispiel zu nennen
und dennoch versuchen wir durch ein
spezielles und hochgradig individuelle
maßnahmen ein bestmögliches maß an
sicherheit und planbarkeit und hygiene
zu gewährleisten
und da geht es uns nicht anders als
vielen anderen unternehmen
ich habe gerade vor kurzem ein interview
gelesen von einem vorstand eines
automobilunternehmens der sagt auch wir
bereiten uns wieder auf den einstieg vor
wir organisieren und planen den gesamten
arbeitstag und das beginnt mit der fiber
messung der mitarbeiter zu hause bis hin
zur organisation des arbeitsplatzes
gleiches wird übrigens auch auf weitere
branchen zu kommen friseure öffnen
nächste woche unter speziellen
voraussetzungen restaurants öffnen unter
speziellen voraussetzungen denn auch
dort wird nicht immer möglich sein
sicherheitsabstand zu halten in küchen
und sie können noch keine glasscheiben
zwischen herde auf steffen je nachdem
wie die bauweise ist gleiches gilt halt
nun mal auch für den profifußball auch
wenn er im gleißenden licht spielt und
wenn ihn alle betrachten und auch wenn
man ihnen oftmals vielleicht auch zu
recht kritisch betrachtet es gibt mit
sicherheit zahlreiche gründe das was wir
ihnen heute vorstellen und das auch das
medizinische konzept und unser vorgehen
zu kritisieren und vielleicht auch
pauschal abzulehnen und vielleicht auch
aus rein emotionalen gründen weil sie es
momentan einfach nicht richtig anfühlt
was vielleicht in diesen zeiten sogar
irgendwie noch nachvollziehbar wäre
was wir jedoch tun können und was wir
tun müssen ist bestmöglich zu versuchen
den die politische verantwortung tragen
ein konzept zu präsentieren dass ein
angemessenes maß an sicherheit und
vorsorge im verhältnis zu den effektiven
gesundheitlichen risiken von spielern
und betreuern darstellt das versuchen
wir
wenn es uns warum und gleich aus welchen
gründen nicht gelingt ein solches
konzept zu präsentieren
dann ist das eben so und dann wäre das
auch zu akzeptieren
dann muss aber eben auch klar sein auch
uns allen dass wir die bundesliga und
zweite bundesliga dann auch in einigen
monaten nicht spielen werden denn mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit sind die
argumente die man heute gegen das
konzept vorbringen kann und die auch in
den letzten tagen wochen zu lesen waren
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit gelten die
halt auch noch in einigen monaten
und insofern wäre die bundesliga dann
irgendwann auch ein kollateralschaden
dieser corona krise und sehen sie sehen
sie es mir bitte nach dass ich hier als
vertreter der klubs
der ich hier bin das nicht als ziel
haben kann sondern wir versuchen
bestmöglich an einem konzept zu arbeiten
um eine fundierte entscheidungsgrundlage
zu schaffen dass die bundesliga früher
oder später wieder in den spielbetrieb
einsteigen kann
folgende schwerpunkte hatte die heutige
sitzung
ich konnte die klubs darüber informieren
dass vereinbarung mit fast allen medien
partnern erzielt wurden
wir haben in den letzten wochen mit
allen partnern intensive gespräche
geführt die waren geprägt von respekt
und vor allem von der gegenseitigen
anerkennung dass diese zeit für alle
eine herausforderung mit negativen
auswirkungen ist das betrifft nicht nur
privathaushalte und viele unternehmen
unter ihnen auch die bundesliga sondern
eben auch sponsoren aber auch unsere
medienpartner die krone krise betrifft
alle unternehmen in deutschland
und was unsere medienanbieter angeht je
nach geschäftsmodell sind unsere partner
unterschiedlich betroffen weshalb wir in
den gesprächen versucht haben den
jeweils individuellen betroffenheiten
rechnung zu tragen
mit einer ausnahme wurden mit allen
partnern vereinbarungen erzielt die den
jeweiligen geschäftsmodellen aber auch
den erworbenen rechtepaketen rechnung
tragen es wurden auch vereinbarung
darüber getroffen wie damit umzugehen
ist sollte diese saison nicht zu ende
gespielt werden können
durch die nun getroffenen vereinbarung
wird schritt wird es schrittweise
möglich allen 36 klubs liquidität bis
30.06 zur verfügung zu stellen
klar ist aber auch sollte die saison
nicht wieder starten oder abgebrochen
werden müssen greifen gewisse
mechanismen zur rückführung von
zahlungen
diese könnten dann erneut zur
wirtschaftlichen engpässen führen
gegebenenfalls zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt ich danke das möchte ich sagen
allen partnern die das ermöglicht haben
besonderer dank gilt dabei natürlich den
mit abstand größten medienpartner der
liga aber auch alle anderen partner
haben mit einer ausnahme im rahmen ihrer
möglichkeiten an einer lösung in dieser
extrem herausfordernden situation
mitgewirkt
weiterhin wurde ein organisationskonzept
vorgestellt und besprochen im falle der
wiederaufnahme des spielbetriebs dieses
hotel für die bundesliga und zweite
bundesliga verbindliche konzepte die den
ablauf möglicher spiele sowohl im
stadioninnenraum als auch im
tribünenbereich und im außengelände
regeln in der bundesliga würde dies
bedeuten für ein spiel ohne zuschauer 98
personen im stadioninnenraum und 115
personen im tribünenbereich also maximal
213 personen in einem stadion auch dem
stadion außengelände sind je nach
stadion bis zu maximal 100 neun weitere
personen vorgesehen
für die zweite bundesliga werden im
stadioninnenraum 90 personen vorgesehen
und 98 im tribünenbereich also insgesamt
188 personen die niedrigere zahl im
vergleich zur bundesliga im innenraum
und nimmt und tribünenbereich ergibt
sich vor allem durch weniger
erforderliche personal für die
produktion des basis signals auf dem
stadion außengelände sind je nach
stadion bis zu maximal 82 personen
vorgesehen für den fall möglicher
spieler ohne zuschauer werden alle klubs
zu sichern diese maximale anzahl an
personen einzuhalten ein weiterer
schwerpunkt der letzten wochen war die
vorbereitung eines medizinische
gälischen konzeptes welches durch die
eigens dafür gebildete task force
erstellt wurde
an dieser stelle nochmal ausdrücklich
meinen dank für den leiter dieser
taskforce professor tim meyer und frau
professor gärtner die uns heute auch
zugeschaltet ist diese task force hat
mit hohem zeitlichen aufwand und sehr
konkret ein wirklich umfassendes konzept
erstellt und das wird auch gleich näher
erläutert wir haben auch hier nach
intensiven gesprächen eine
kooperationsvereinbarung zur
fachärztlichen unterstützung
abgeschlossen mit insgesamt fünf labor
verbünden
alle fünf labore sind mitglieder des
verbandes akkreditierte akkreditierte
labore in der medizin
dabei handelt es sich um die unternehmen
sonic healthcare lh dr
labor berlin süd ab und dr display auf
diese werden durch eine bundesweite
abdeckung fachärztlicher labore eine
umsetzung des konzeptes unterstützen
weiterhin werden wir mit dem unternehmen
sonic healthcare einen vertrag
abschließen zur flächendeckenden
antikörper testung der spieler der
bundesliga und zweiten bundesliga in
form einer klinischen studie
alle labore haben uns schriftlich
versichert dass die derzeitigen
kapazitäten ausreichend sind und durch
coop 19 tests von spielern der
bundesliga und zweiten bundesliga sowie
betreuern keine einschränkungen oder
limitierungen der test kapazitäten
auftreten
laut lagebericht des robert koch
instituts vom 22 april liegt das volumen
der test kapazitäten aktuell bei 818
1000 tests pro woche auf basis von
wochen arbeitstage
der profifußball würde davon nicht
einmal 0,4 prozent beanspruchen
es ist außerdem davon auszugehen dass
die in deutschland verfügbaren
laborkapazitäten sogar noch weiter
zunehmen werden
die dfl wird über das geplante test
volumen hinaus für 500.000 euro weitere
test kapazitäten kontrahieren die wir in
absprache mit dem gesundheitsministerium
dem öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst zur
verfügung stellen um zb in pflegeheimen
bei bedarf testen zu können sollte
ausgleich welchen gründen der test
bedarf der klubs geringer ausfallen wird
diese werden diese kapazitäten ebenfalls
dem öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst zur
verfügung gestellt ich darf ihnen
versichern wenn wir den spielbetrieb
aufnehmen dürfen
dann werden wir das tun was in dieser
krise in jedem unternehmen und ebenso in
der politik das gebot der stunde ist wir
werden von tag zu tag immer wieder aufs
neue prüfen was verantwortbar ist und
das stets in dem wissen dass es in
diesen zeiten keine 100% richtige lösung
geben kann
wir werden das alles sehr genau
verfolgen und es ist bewusst dass für
den fall den sich wirklich niemand
wünscht dass nämlich zum beispiel sich
die lage wieder verschlechtert und test
kapazitäten tatsächlich zum engpass
würden der profifußball
selbstverständlich zurückstehen muss und
selbstverständlich zurück stehen wird
nationale gesundheit hat immer vorrang
und das kann und das darf auch gar nicht
anders sein
und ich habe wie sie wissen von
vorneherein ausgeschlossen dass wir
anderweitig benötigte medizinische
kapazität mit blockieren und dabei
bleibt es wenn es erforderlich ist dann
wird der profi fußball aufhören zu
testen und dann wird er auch aufhören zu
spielen
wir haben die mitgliederversammlung
außerdem darüber informiert dass das
präsidium in seiner sitzung am dienstag
einen ersten beschluss zur teilweisen
verwendung des solidarfonds gefasst hat
das durch die
champions-league-teilnehmer
bereitgestellt wurde demnach soll mit
einer summe von 75 millionen euro
kurzfristig die dritte liga sowie die
frauen bundesliga unterstützt werden
alle clubs der bundesliga der 1
mannschaft in einer der beiden ligen
spielen haben ihren verzicht erklärt auf
ihren ihren verzicht erklärt auf ihren
rechnerischen anteil an dieser so das
sind in der dritten liga der fc bayern
münchen in der frauen-bundesliga die
klubs fc bayern münchen vfl wolfsburg sc
freiburg erst fc köln bayer leverkusen
und tsg hoffenheim
als folge daraus hat das präsidium
entschieden dass insgesamt 25
mannschaften aus dritter liga und frauen
bundesliga diese 7,5 millionen erhalten
jeweils zu gleichen teilen diese
unterstützungszahlungen sind
ausdrücklich an keine weiteren
bedingungen geknüpft wir werden uns
kurzfristig mit dem dfb in verbindung
setzen um die abwicklung dieser
solidaritäts zahlung zu besprechen und
das präsidium dankt auf diesem wege
nochmals ausdrücklich den diesjährigen
champions league klubs fc bayern
borussia dortmund bayer leverkusen rb
leipzig für die initiative zur
bereitstellung des solidarfonds vielen
dank vielen dank dann darf ich über
leighton zu hoeren professor meyer herr
meyer wies die arbeit der task force
verlaufen können sie die kernergebnisse
beschreiben
vielen dank wenn ich die arbeit der task
force ist über wenige wochen verlaufen
wir haben ein sehr enger zeitlicher
taktung uns per video-konferenz
zusammengeschlossen mit insgesamt acht
personen die namen sind glaube ich
bekannt und die aufgabenstellung der
taskforce war ein szenario zu erarbeiten
wie der professionelle fußball mit einem
vertretbaren medizinischen risiko wieder
stattfinden kann
dabei haben wir sicherlich nicht das rad
neu erfinden müssen wir haben aber die
für alle geltenden hygienischen
prinzipien und maßregeln auf den
profifußball und seine typischen
rahmenbedingungen herunter brechen
müssen das ganze resultierte in einem
etwas etwa 50 seitigen dokument daran
erkennen sie schon das sehr kleinteilig
auch viele details zu berücksichtigen
waren im grunde genommen untergliedert
sich dieses szenario in drei säulen die
erste säule ist das sogenannte infekt
monitoring das heißt über den gesamten
ablauf einer eventuell stattfindenden
saison aber auch bereits seit bestehen
der task force und seit auftreten der
ersten fälle haben wir fälle in den
vereinen bei spielern und beim
betreuungspersonal registriert
anonymisiert registriert und die die
verläufe der fälle genauso wie die frage
ob krankenhausaufenthalt notwendig waren
die ansteckung situation dies analysiert
und das wird fortgeführt auch über den
rest der saison so sie denn stattfindet
der die zweite säule betrifft die
trainingsstätten und die stadien
dort wurden die prinzipien der des
distanz halten und das
zurverfügungstellen von
desinfektionsmittel seife und ähnlichen
dingen sehr genau unter gebrochen auf
die rahmenbedingungen in den
umkleideräumen in den duschen es wurde
darauf achtgeben dass verschiedene
gruppen die dort notwendig sind nicht
nur die spieler und betreuer sondern
vielleicht auch die kamera leute
entsprechend getrennt sind das schlicht
und einfach das ansteckungsrisiko
minimiert wird
darüber hinaus und das ist die dritte
säule sollen regelmäßige tests
durchgeführt werden mit denen wiederum
von test zu test immer sicherer
garantiert wird dass in dieser gruppe
von spielern und betreuern keine infekte
auftreten
diese tests sind die klassischen
abstriche die ja in der bevölkerung
bekannt sind und von herrn seifert eben
schon angesprochen auch begleitend
antikörpertest um vernünftig auch den
erfolg unserer maßnahme am ende
beurteilen zu können und vielleicht auch
informationen an die bevölkerung oder an
andere sporttreibende oder andere
sportarten weitergeben zu können
herr meyer vielen dank dann darf ich zu
frau gärtner übergehen frau professor
gärtner welche punkte der taskforce sind
vor allem aus virologische hygienischer
sicht hervorzuheben
wir haben versucht mit verschiedensten
maßnahmen das risiko zu minimieren für
alle beteiligten für die betreuer für
die spieler für die schiedsrichter
und eben auch für die ganzen mitarbeiter
im stadion
und dazu gehören zwei kernpunkte das
eine ist die abstandsregelung und das
andere ist die testung und eben auch die
symptomkontrolle der spieler und
derjenigen die eben die
abstandskontrolle nicht einhalten können
ganz wichtig war auch für jede
mannschaft hygienebeauftragte
einzurichten deren hauptaufgabe es ist
wirklich darauf hinzuweisen dass die
regelungen alle ein
halten werden oftmals ist es so dass
wenn einem menschen gut bekannt sind man
das gefühl für den richtigen abstand
verliert bei fremden ist uns das relativ
gut möglich aber bei menschen die uns
bekannt sind geht oftmals das gefühl
verloren die weiter abstand wirklich ist
und dafür brauchen wir die
hygienebeauftragten die beiden
mannschaften immer wieder darauf achten
dass diese regeln auch wirklich alle
eingehalten werden
dazu gibt es eine ganze reihe von
regelungen für den häuslichen bereich
damit die spieler und betreuer eben sich
auch im häuslichen bereich keinem
zusätzlichen risiko aussetzen
und das erfordert natürlich eine ganze
menge an disziplin im umgang mit den
mitmenschen zu hause vielen dank frau
professor gärtner
vielen dank für die statements ich würde
sagen damit starten wir die fragerunde
und beginnen mit eric dobias von der dpa
ja
schönen guten tag nach frankfurt
verlagert hat finde ich ja meyer hat es
noch ein sorry hab jetzt nur 73 auf dem
problem gesehen wollte sie nicht
erschlagen entschuldigung so gerne zum
einstieg eine frage an herrn seifert
die saison ist ja offiziell momentan bis
zum 30 april ausgesetzt
sie haben es jetzt in ihrem
eingangsstatement vermieden da ein einer
neue deadline zu setzen
welchen hintergrund hat das erste mal
das erste maiwochenende ist ja
wahrscheinlich noch ausgeschlossen als
als spieltermin und ist der neunte meyer
sofern die signale nächste woche aus der
politik kämen im zusammenhang mit einer
vernünftigen vorbereitung stichwort
mannschaftstraining überhaupt denkbar
vielen dank herr tobias für die frage
sie haben genau zugehört genau so ist es
wir haben heute keinen zeitpunkt
definiert zudem die bundesliga wieder
spielen soll einfach deshalb weil wir
das nicht können weil das nicht in
unserer kompetenz liegt weil das auch
nicht unsere aufgabe ist ich habe da
schon mehrfach darauf hingewiesen wir
haben es letztlich nicht in der hand ob
wir überhaupt spielen und wenn ja wann
sondern wir haben nur in der hand die
rahmenbedingungen dafür zu schaffen die
denjenigen die die verantwortung haben
eine entscheidung treffen zu müssen
bestmöglich das gefühl vermittelt ja die
bundesliga ist bereit die können dass
die haben sich gedanken gemacht die
wissen was sie zu tun haben um das maß
zu finden zwischen den gefahren die in
dieser krise nummer laune und dem was
wahrscheinlich ist und was passieren
könnte im rahmen der produktion eines
fußballspiels der spielbetrieb ist bis
zunächst ausgesetzt wir haben auch beim
letzten mal klar zwei optionen
präsentiert eine beginnend mai eine
neunter mehrere spielplan optionen wie
sie sich vorstellen können
es ist sicherlich nicht mehr realistisch
davon auszugehen am ersten mai
wochenende zu starten das war es aber
das war auch irgendwann klar dass das so
nicht mehr sein würde
das thema der vorbereitung spielt
sicherlich eine rolle ist aber momentan
ein stück weit auch nachgelagert zu
sehen weil dankenswerter weise können
unsere klubs schon seit einiger zeit
mindestens mal in kleingruppen wieder
trainieren dh es ist nicht ein
kompletter kaltstart wie der
beispielsweise irgendwann vielleicht in
england italien oder spanien der fall
ist wo team seit wochen nicht trainieren
dürfen wir sind hier in deutschland
tatsächlich schon ein gutes stück weiter
und insofern wenn das signal kommen
würde
im laufe der nächsten woche es ist er
neunter mai dann werden wir am 9 mai
bereit sein und wenn das signal später
kommt dann werden wir zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt bereit sein
ich glaube was ganz wichtig ist zu
betonen wir profitieren die de facto von
einem der modernsten medizinischen
systeme einer der modernsten
medizinischen infrastrukturen der welt
und dort sowohl von den
managementkapazitäten aber auch von dem
politischen management
und wenn wir wieder spielen dürfen dann
liegt das nicht daran dass die
bundesliga so großartig ist sondern weil
wir in einem land leben in dem das
möglich ist und die nachfragen
international von unternehmen von sport
liegen aus den usa aus ganz europa wie
sieht das konzept aus
die häufen sich quasi täglich denn die
tatsache dass wir überhaupt wieder in
der lage sind über so etwas nachzudenken
zeigt ja in erster linie einmal die
leistungsfähigkeit der deutschen
medizinischen infrastruktur und die art
und weise wie diese krise hier gemanagt
wurde
andere länder sind da noch lichtjahre
von entfernt und insofern werden wir uns
darauf vorbereiten wenn das signal kommt
wieder in den spielbetrieb einzusteigen
ein datum festzulegen wäre anmaßend
gehört sich auch nicht liegt nicht an
uns dann darf ich aufrufen christian
kamp von der faz
ja hallo ans podium
wenn ich habe ja und auch an die
zugeschaltete professoren ein
medizinischer knackpunkt scheint mir zu
sein die frage ob es seiner gruppen
quarantäne kommen kann oder nicht
frage 1 seifert ist das tatsächlich der
knackpunkt also kann so ein fall das
system zum sturz bringen und fragen an
die medizinischen experten wann wäre ein
fall an der solchen gruppen quarantäne
nötig ich würde vielleicht das wort
zuerst an die medizinischen experten
geben und im nachgang wenn das noch
erforderlich ist würde ich dann
antwortet euro positionieren frau
gärtner bitte
also wenn ein testergebnis positiv ist
dann ist das erst mal eine
meldepflichtige erkrankung das wird an
das gesundheitsamt gemeldet und das
gesundheitsamt entscheidet auf den
kriterien die das robert-koch-institut
herausgibt ob eine quarantäne notwendig
ist oder nicht das entscheiden also gar
nicht die vereine direkt die vereine
könnten zusätzlich wenn das
gesundheitsamt eben keine quarantäne
anordnen würde darüber hinaus durchaus
auch noch selber quarantäne anordnen
aber in erster linie ist das tatsächlich
nicht die entscheidung der vereine
herr meyer betrifft vielleicht darf
ergänzen dass ja die die kontaktpersonen
durch das robert-koch-institut
klassifiziert werden und dass wir durch
das bündel dieser ganzen maßnahmen der
meinung sind dass man unsere spieler und
betreuer nicht als hochrisiko
kontaktpersonen klassifizieren muss und
das ist damit durchaus berechtigt
gerechtfertigt wäre nicht sofort eine
mannschaft in quarantäne zu schicken
wäre das der fall wäre das ja quasi
einem saison abbruch gleichzusetzen
wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf das
konzept orientiert sich da in der tat an
den empfehlungen des
robert-koch-institutes dass er im
prinzip zwei kontaktpersonen klassen
definiert eine kontaktperson 1 ist
tatsächlich eine kontaktperson die
kontakt hatte mit einer kurve 19
getesteten personen länger als 15
minuten in einem echten in einer face to
face situation und kontaktpersonen zwei
es sind kontaktpersonen die tatsächlich
mit einer kurve 19 identifiziert
identifiziert infizierten infizierten
personen in einem raum sind länger als
15 minuten
ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig noch mal
vorwegzunehmen dass sich auch der umgang
mit quarantäne konzepten wie schon frau
professor gärtner sagte erstes mal an
den gesundheitsämtern orientieren muss
und zweitens wir werden auch hierzu sich
möglicherweise angepassten quarantäne
konzepten kommen denn wenn es so sein
sollte dass die schulen schrittweise
wieder öffnen und eine lehrkraft sollte
tatsächlich
wieder sollte sich infizieren dann wird
es eben kaum sein können dass man die
schule wieder schließt gleiches gilt
unter umständen für andere
industriebetriebe also der umgang mit
quarantäne fällen wird sicherlich ein
ganz ganz entscheidender aspekt seien
deshalb auch ein sehr umfassendes
konzept auf der anderen seite hoffen wir
natürlich in relation setzen zu können
dass das robert-koch-institut wie es
heute morgen meldete über 2400 neue
kroner fälle berichtet bei dem
gesamtvolumen von knapp etwa 150000 in
einem land mit 83 millionen menschen
also insofern ist erstmal die
eigenverantwortung eines jeden scheint
ja zu funktionieren tatsächlich mit
diesem virus umzugehen und auch mit
entsprechenden ansteckungszahlen
umzugehen klar ist dass wir wie ich
schon sagte gewisse abstandsregel nicht
halten können klar ist auch dass es zu
körper kontakten kommt und die frage ob
man dann in einem normalen fußballspiel
mit einem simplen körperkontakt oder mit
körperkontakt im zweikampfverhalten etc
oder auch im training ein virus
übertragen kann
das liegt dann an medizinern das zu
beurteilen und zumindest mal unsere task
force ist zu dem schluss gekommen dass
dieses konzept ein ausgewogenes maß an
schutz vor dem hintergrund möglicher
biologische risiken darstellt dann darf
ich jan christian müller von der
frankfurter rundschau aufrufen
ja mich würde interessieren haben klubs
bedenken geäußert hinsichtlich eines
sehr zeitnahen einer zeitnahen
wiederaufnahme der saison schon im mai
sowohl moralischer gesellschaftlicher
natur als auch ganz konkret was den
spielbetrieb angeht und den schutz von
spielern und betreuern unmöglich auch
risiko-patienten in der heutigen in der
heutigen sitzung wurde seitens der klubs
boden seiten der klubs keine bedenken
angemeldet möglicherweise schon wieder
im mai zu starten unsere kontakte mit
den klubs haben auch nichts
diesbezüglich ist ergeben
es gibt lediglich den gedanken dass man
eine mindest trainingszeit natürlich
braucht um entsprechend verletzungen zu
vermeiden
aber wir haben auch im konzept
vorgesehen dass spieler natürlich
vernünftig über mögliche risiken
informiert werden und letztlich ihr
freier wille entscheidet ob sie spielen
aber um auf ihre frage zurückzukommen
eigentlich kann ich das nur verneinen
dann dürfen wir weitermachen mit michael
ebert vom kicker einen schönen guten tag
in die runde mich würde interessieren
wie viele tests denn nun tatsächlich
benötigt werden wie groß die abstände
sind man getestet wird und wieso man
wert in dem konzept darauf gelegt hat
das keinen positiven ergebnisse
veröffentlicht werden
das könnte ja auch könnte ja auch anonym
der fall sein dass man nur den verein
benennt um den spieler selbst zu
schützen
herr meyer wollen sie ja also zunächst
mal ist es so wenn ich mache mal eine
einfache rechnung zunächst auf wir haben
36 vereine
wir gehen davon aus dass pro verein
circa 40 personen zu test und das 40
personen zu testen sind nehmen wir mal
an es dauert zehn wochen und wir haben
im konzept stehen mindestens einmal pro
woche
denn käme ich auf 14.400 tests nun sind
verschiedene szenarien denkbar die diese
zahlen noch verändern also zum einen ist
die zwei von zehn wochen wahrscheinlich
fast ein bisschen hochgegriffen wir
könnten er bei acht oder neun liegen das
würde die zwei verringern
wir werden aber auf der anderen seite
eine wahrscheinlich englische wochen
haben so dass mehrfach pro woche
getestet werden muss so dass die annahme
einer zahl von rund 20.000 sicherlich
realistisch ist da gibt es also ist es
eher wahrscheinlich dass es weniger
werden jetzt dass es dass es darüber
hinaus geht denn wir werden
normalerweise nicht die zehn wochen
bekommen zehn wochen spielzeit bekommen
vielleicht kann ich ja noch so wollen
sie das thema der warum sollen die namen
nicht veröffentlicht werden sie haben
glaube ich eben schon gesagt herr ebert
es ist natürlich gang und gäbe in der
bundesliga auch medial durchgesetzt dass
man sagt der spieler fällt aus mit einer
mit einer oberschenkelzerrung
in diesem fall und das hat ja eben schon
frau professor gärtner angemerkt haben
wir natürlich mit einem anderen fall zu
tun sondern in dem fall ist tatsächlich
kommt bei einer testung heraus dass es
ein pool möglicher weise einen positiven
test gab und dann wird erst mal das
gesundheitsamt informiert das ist auch
unter datenschutzrechtlichen
gesichtspunkten nicht so dass man dass
da mal eben schon auf die website stellt
aber insgesamt ist anzumerken dass man
dann natürlich irgendwann in die
kommunikation geht nur das ist eben
nichts was man mal gleichsetzen kann mit
einer oberschenkelzerrung insgesamt
vielleicht auch noch mal zur einordnung
bisher und das hat die task force auch
ermittelt in den letzten wochen von den
1100 lizenzspielern gab es 14 positiv
getestete fälle die sind auch in der
zwischenzeit alle längst wieder genesen
und jedenfalls meiner information nach
stand gestern ist er seither auch keiner
dazu gekommen und ich glaube das sollten
wir bei allen debatten und nochmal ich
kann nachvollziehen dass die auch sehr
sehr emotional teilweise geführt werden
weil es auch ein emotionales thema ist
weil das natürlich uns im alltag
begegnet im wahrsten sinn des wortes nun
demnächst je nach je nach mundschutz
auflagen vielleicht noch häufiger
wir werden jeden tag daran erinnert aber
am ende ist es natürlich auch die eigene
verantwortung eines jeden gesund zu
bleiben
das geht in einigen berufen vielleicht
leichter als in anderen aber ich sehe
schon auch dass es erforderlich ist
genau für diese ihn dann etwa 1100
lizenzspieler oder die 40 personen pro
starb genau wie für jeden anderen
arbeitnehmer in deutschland auch erstmal
darauf zu achten dass er sich eben nicht
ansteckt und wenn das alle tatsächlich
tun
dann kann vermeintlich relativ wenig
passieren das engmaschige netz dass wir
spannen ist ja genau dazu da um hier den
sicherheitsfaktor noch einmal zu erhöhen
aber die frage stecke ich mich an wenn
ich morgen zur arbeit geht die haben wir
alle und je mehr arbeitsplätze sich auch
entwickeln wo eben nicht immer abstände
gehalten werden können umso mehr stellt
sich diese frage
wir versuchen für unseren speziellen
rahmen des profifußballs darauf mit
diesem medizinische dänischen konzept
eine
antwort zu finden und das in einem
gesellschaftlich vertretenen zu
vertretenden rahmen erst recht wenn es
eben um laborkapazitäten in deutschland
geht die wir nun mal nach heutigem stand
nicht signifikant belasten werden das
haben uns alle labore bestätigt und es
gibt auch keinen zweifel dass es gibt
auch keinen grund das in irgendeiner art
und weise zu bezweifeln ich wiederhole
noch mal
sollte sich das ändern warum auch immer
müsste es einen zweiten lockdown geben
gibt es fragwürdige entwicklung in
deutschland die das erfordern
selbstverständlich wird dann die
bundesliga hinten anstellen und wir
würden dann sämtliche test kapazitäten
die wir vertraglich vereinbart haben dem
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst zur
verfügung stellen alexander hübner von
reuters die eine ausnahme ist sowas
sagen und gewesen dass man darf bei
abschläge hinnehmen mussten sie auch
dazu etwas sagen das interessanteste
aber wäre angesagt bis 30 mich an einige
der letzten pressekonferenzen erinnern
wo 66 haben könnten schon einige
unternehmen oder ein
vielen dank für die für die frage die
über dreigeteilte überdies mehr richtig
kommentiert habe also erstens es gibt
ein unternehmen mit dem wir keine
vereinbarung erzielt haben das ist nicht
der sohn mit der sohn haben wir eine
vereinbarung erzielt und da sind auch
die spielregeln klar entschuldigung ob
es bei einzelnen zahlungen zu abschlägen
kommt erstens wenn es so wäre wären das
vertragsbestandteile über die würde ich
jetzt keine auskunft geben
zum zweiten
hängt das natürlich auch ein stück weit
davon ab wie die saison zu ende gespielt
wird würden wir zum beispiel aufgrund
eines weiteren saisonverlaufs relativ
wenige wochenenden spielen können dann
wäre dadurch ganz objektiv die das
rechtepaket nicht nur unsere partner
sondern zum beispiel auch von ard und
zdf betroffen denn das zdf zeigt
normalerweise samstagsabends des
sportstudio wenn es das sportstudio in
einem übergroßen maße einfach gar nicht
gäbe weil wir vor allem dienstag am
mittwoch spielen oder dienstag
donnerstag und samstag und dann eben
wieder weiter weiß ich nicht unter der
woche dann wäre das natürlich in
einzubeziehen und gleich es natürlich
auch für die ard sportschau wo ein recht
der zusammenfassung natürlich auch ein
anderes ist wenn man vor 20 uhr
ausstrahlen darf wo noch werbung möglich
ist in der ard oder eben am späten
dienstag oder mittwochabend und sollte
es dazu kommen dass der finale spiel
planen dann fest steht wenn es ihnen
geben wird dann werden wir sehr genau
ansehen wie der aussieht und das sehen
dann auch die vereinbarung aus dass wir
dann in genauso partnerschaftlichen
gesprächen das lösen ja also ist es
nicht der song und ob es abschläge gibt
kann ich nicht kommentieren aber klar
ist dass der weitere verlauf effekte hat
auf die wertigkeit der rechte die noch
zu vergeben sind und die frage nach dem
30 06
tut mir leid sollte falls ich das falsch
ausgedrückt habe ich sagte es wird
möglich sein den klubs liquidität bis
zum 30.06 zukommen zu lassen das heißt
nicht dass wir die am 30 06 überweisen
es ist vorgesehen dass jetzt im mai
erste zahlung kurzfristig ausgelöst
werden an die klubs später vom
sportinformationsdienst bitte schön
guten tag in die runde
meine frau richtet sich an die
medizinischen experten
wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe
wird der letzte test von spieler am tag
vor dem spiel stattfinden bei den
spielern
was passiert danach mit dem spielern
müssen sie sich dann komplett isolieren
und ist dieser zeitraum von über einem
tag dann bis zum spiel nicht zu lange
dass man da ruhigen gewissens ins spiel
gehen kann
ich würde sagen zunächst vor gärtner
dann herr meier
wenn wir einen test vom freitag haben
und am samstag gespielt wird dann ist
eigentlich nicht damit zu rechnen dass
es in einer so kurzen zeit zu einer
infektion kommen kann und wiederum zu
einer virus ausscheidung also am tag
nach einer infektion ist niemand
infektiös das dauert immer eine ganze
weile es genügend virus produziert ist
so dass es dann ausgeschieden wird also
das dauert sicher zwei drei tage minimum
am ersten tag kann da nichts passieren
und deswegen bewegen wir uns mit dieser
zeitschiene in einem sehr sicheren
zeitraum
ich würde gerne dazu sagen herr müller
hat was von der quadratur des kreises
geschrieben die wir hätten finden müssen
ich denke es geht darum einen
vernünftigen kompromiss zwischen
maximaler sicherheit und vertretbare
medizinischen risiko zu finden
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich klar wenn
sie jemanden alle sechs stunden testen
dass das eine höhere sicherheit bietet
als wenn sie das alle drei tage machen
aber wir sind wirklich der meinung und
barbara gärtner hat er eben die
hauptargumente genannt dass dies
hinrainer vertretbar sicher ist dann
darf ich weitermachen mit marc schmidt
von der bild zeitung
schön groß ins saarland und auch in die
ode nach frankfurt meine frage richtet
sich an der mauer und auch beim herrn
seifert unsere informationen nach war
betreffen den 9 mai mannschaftstrainings
staat rund um den 27
april geplant ist dem weiterhin so und
glauben sie dass die mannschaften dann
auf dem neunten mal betreffend match fit
sind also quasi dass sie tatsächlich
zwei wochen mannschaftstraining
ausreichen werden um damit der
bundesliga zu spielen
also ich hatte ihre informationen nicht
insofern fretter seifert die konzepte
die wir vorgelegen haben habt kalt haben
keinen trainingsstart vorgesehen
es ist sicherlich so dass es aussagen
aus der liga gibt dass man zwei wochen
mannschaftstraining braucht um wieder in
den spielbetrieb ein schatten zu können
ob das dann eben daher zwei wochen sind
zehn tage drei wochen kann ich ihnen
nicht sagen
ich glaube das wort match fit so muss so
fair muss man auch mal sein ist inmitten
einer corona krise nach zwei monaten und
nach zwei monaten unterbrochen im
spielbetrieb vielleicht auch ein
bisschen in relation zu setzen
wir spielen hier wenn wir wieder spielen
dürfen unter absoluten ausnahme
bedingungen das ist dann auch nicht zu
vergleichen mit einem normalen
spielbetrieb wo man vielleicht mal eine
woche pause hat weil man international
nicht spielt oder es gibt einfach eine
abstellungsperioden für die
international spielen den spieler
sondern wir haben stand heute ein spiel
durchgeführt oder das letzte spiel
durchgeführt wenn wir am 9 mai oder im
mai wieder starten würden das was zwei
monate her ist
ich glaube das ist dann auch der
sportliche bereich gefordert eine
gewisse flexibilität an den tag zu legen
klar ist dass es sicherlich irgendwann
mal ein zeitfenster gibt wo es dann zu
kurz wird
aber das ist nicht an uns da jetzt
irgendwelche forderungen zu stellen
sondern die politik wird irgendwann eine
entscheidung treffen ob wir wieder
spielen dürfen und wenn ja wann und
daraus leitet sich dann ab wann wir
logischerweise auch wieder in geordnete
das mannschaftstraining einsteigen
müssten und wandern der realistische
erster spieltag ist der 27 april als
fester termin für ein
mannschaftstraining ist in keinem
konzept das jedenfalls ich kenne
vorgesehen ich möchte auch sagen dass
die taskforce nie von irgendwelchen
daten ausgegangen ist unser konzept ist
auch unabhängig davon wann begonnen
würde dann machen wir weiter mit philipp
selldorf von der süddeutschen zeitung
ja hallo sonntag
ich hätte noch eine frage zu gruppen
quarantäne
falls es dann doch mal ein fall geben
sollte wo das notwendig sein sollte wird
dann die betreffende mannschaft
sozusagen aus dem wettbewerb genommen
und die spiele dieser mannschaft werden
dann zunächst mal ausfallen und später
nachgeholt und wer
betrieb läuft dann weiter oder wie ist
das vorgesehen was die entscheidung über
eine gruppen quarantäne angeht hatte er
gerade eben frau professor gärtner
ausgeführt dass diese entscheidung nicht
von der liga zu treffen ist sollte der
fall eintreten haben wir im spielplan
theoretisch natürlich flexibilität in
unter umständen auch spiele nachholen zu
können wenn das gehäuft der fall wäre
dann würde das irgendwann sicherlich zu
einer problematischen termin
konstellation führen weshalb das konzept
und die eigene verantwortung des
einzelnen aber auch die verantwortung
der klubs dieses konzept umzusetzen ja
gerade darauf abzielt dass es im
idealfall nicht zu diesen fällen kommt
was hoffentlich angesichts der sich
verzögernden ausbreitung des virus und
der abnehmenden anzahl von ansteckungen
für diesen sehr begrenzten personenkreis
dann auch irgendwie abbildbar wäre aber
klar ist wenn sich die situation stellen
und es gibt eine gruppen quarantäne dann
gibt es die das entscheiden nicht wir
und dann werden wir damit irgendwie
umzugehen wissen dann machen wir weiter
mit der zweiten runde eric dobias von
der deutschen presse agentur
ja nochmal nachfrage an herrn seifert am
kommenden donnerstag gibt es ja die
nächste große runde zwischen der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und den
ministerpräsidenten erwarten sie denn an
dem tag schon die entscheidung aus der
politik ob es grünes licht für den
profifußball gibt und wenn ja haben sie
heute mit allen vereinen schon alle
szenarien soweit durchgespielt dass sie
dann ohne eine neue schalter noch mal am
neunten mal loslegen könnt nur da müssen
sie sich dann noch mal alle zusammen
schalten um dann genau den regularien
für einen neustart noch mal zu
diskutieren
herr tobias wendl/tobias wenn es
erforderlich wäre machen wir auch hier
schalten in zwei tagen in diesen zeiten
ist eine schalte oder der
abstimmungsbedarf den wir zu leisten
haben
es wäre für uns das geringste problem
das können sie mir glauben
wann wer welche entscheidungen trifft
liegt überhaupt nicht an uns wir wissen
und wir nehmen das unser dass das dass
das konzept der das organisationskonzept
dass jain tatsächlich mehr ist als nur
ein hygienisch medizinisches konzept
sondern ein organisationskonzept dass
auch personen zahlen vorsieht dass
arbeitsabläufe vorzieht das extrem
ausdifferenziert ist wir nehmen das dass
in der politik angekommen ist wir nehmen
auch dass das robert koch institut das
begutachten wird
ich habe auch eben gelesen dass die
bundesanstalt für arbeitsschutz sich mit
dem thema beschäftigen wird und das
finde ich auch alles absolut angemessen
wir haben immer gesagt wir wollen hier
keine sonderrolle für den fußball aber
klar ist dass jede industrie ihre
besonderheiten hat und ich glaube das
ist der der spagat den ist vielleicht
liegt das auch an mir den denen es nicht
gelungen ist in der öffentlichkeit so
richtig war
so richtig so richtig darzustellen ja
die besonderheiten des profifußballs
erfordern einfach ein solches konzept
wenn man weiterspielen möchte dass
weiterzuspielen erstens der beschluss
oder weiterspielen zu wollen erstens der
beschluss war von allen 36 klubs am 16
märz das haben alle klar zum ausdruck
gebracht
und dass daran zu arbeiten weiter
spielen zu können die aufgabe der dfl
ist die aufgabe des dfl präsidium ist
die aufgabe aller mitarbeiter und
natürlich auch meine aufgabe das bedingt
eben dass wir dann an solchen konzepten
arbeiten und wenn die kritisiert werden
oder zerlegt werden teilweise auch mit
nahmen missgunst die mich schon auch
überrascht wo ich mich auch frage woran
liegt das was hat der profi-fußball
falsch gemacht in den letzten jahren
dann ist das jetzt auch zu akzeptieren
was aus dieser krise hängen bleiben wird
ist sicherlich nicht nur wie geht man
medizinisch und hygienisch damit um
sondern vielleicht die ein oder andere
entwicklung der letzten jahre auch noch
mal sehr sehr kritisch gemeinsam mit den
klubs zu diskutieren
um sich zu fragen warum da
offensichtlich jedenfalls bei einigen
akteuren und bei einigen menschen warum
da doch relativ wenig gut wird zu
verzeichnen ist aber unsere aufgabe
besteht darin der der politik die auf
unserer branche zugeschnittenen aspekte
oder die auf unsere die sich in dieser
branche ergebenden fragestellungen so in
einem konzept zu gießen
dass man guten gewissens weiß wenn die
politik uns das spiel erlaubt oder die
zuständigen behörden und die politischen
gegner politischen verantwortung stehen
dafür wenn sie uns das spiel erlaubt
dass sie sich dann auf dieses konzept
verlassen kann und dass dieses konzept
so ausgestaltet ist dass für diesen
speziellen berufszweig das risiko
vertretbar erscheint und ob diese
entscheidung nächsten donnerstag fällt
davor danach oder wann auch immer das
ist nicht unsere entscheidung das
respektieren wir voll und ganz
wir machen weiter mit jan christian
müller von der frankfurter rundschau
tschuldigung müller ich habe verstanden
ich wollte gucken ob ich es über die box
besser versteht sich sie haben gefragt
ob die saison am 30.6 beendet sein muss
ja
die saison sollte am 30.06 beendet sein
wenn es nach uns geht wir glauben nach
wie vor dass das auch unter dem aspekt
der vertragsstabilität insbesondere was
arbeitsverträge mit spielern angeht der
beste termin wäre wenn die saison in den
juli reichen würde wäre das auch
abbildbar und ist auch mit den
medienpartnern so vereinbart und
besprochen
je früher wir fertig sind umso größer
die klarheit für alle beteiligten und
umso mehr möglichkeiten das war ja beim
letzten mal auch ein thema natürlich
auch für unsere europäischen kollegen
und auch eine uefa ihre wettbewerber
ihrerseits zu versuchen zu beenden
ja der dreißigste sechster ist ein
termin den wir anstreben wenn das in den
juli hinein reichen sollte dann geht es
in den juli ein
dann hat dann christian kamp bitte von
der faz
ja ich hätte noch einmal einen nachtrag
zum thema gruppen quarantäne haben ja
ich hatte vorhin so verstanden dass in
einem solchen fall das mit einem mit dem
abbruch gleichzusetzen wäre das kleine
zweifel etwas anders deswegen einfach
die frage ob das ist ob ich das
missverstanden habe und meine
eigentliche frage ist sollte ich das
sehe ist ja die teilnahme an den spielen
auch für die spieler letztlich
freiwillig wir müssen über ihre
gesundheit dem fall selbst verfügen gab
es signale jetzt heute aus den vereinen
dass es spieler gibt einzelne wurde
zweimal in nennenswerter zahl die nicht
bereit ist unter diesen prämissen zu
geisterspielen anzutreten
nein diese hinweise gab es nicht und ich
glaube die diskrepanz zwischen meine
aussagen der von herrn seifert liegt
vielleicht daran dass ich etwas
undifferenziert angenommen habe
das quasi eine ganze mannschaft ein
gesamter kader automatisch für 14 tage
in quarantäne ginge das ist natürlich
nicht automatisch so dass kann auch eine
kleinere gruppe seien die betroffenen
ist wo dass da durchaus noch darstellbar
wäre wenn eine mannschaft komplett 14
tage aufhören müsste zu drehen
trainieren und zu spielen
dann denke ich wird es sicherlich
schwierig aber auch da mag es noch
termin szenarien geben über das habe ich
nicht durchgerechnet
aber dann wird sicherlich eng dann
machen wir weiter mit michael ebert vom
kicker weshalb
wo wird denn angesetzt wenn am 9
der 16 mai die saison fortgeführt werden
kann wird dann der 33 spieltag gespielt
oder sechsundzwanzigster und wo ist noch
platz für dfb pokal europa league und
champions league was noch aussteht
mit welchem spieltag weiter gemacht wird
ist jetzt noch nicht entschieden das
liegt in der hoheit der dfl die würde
das dann auch finale entscheiden im
rahmen ihrer ansetzung hoheit die sie
nun mal hat da ist bisher noch keine
entscheidungen gefallen
das wollen wir auch davon abhängig
machen sobald der termin feststeht was
sind dfb-pokal angeht wo da noch platz
ist das müssten sie mit dem dfb
besprechen europa league und champions
league da gibt es überlegungen bei der
uefa und
die sind ja auch bekannt die wehr oder
zumindest mal wurden öffentlich schon
diskutiert dass auch vor dem hintergrund
der europäischen wettbewerbe und auch
möglicherweise szenarien et cetera was
ja noch viel viel größere komplexitäten
und fragezeichen beinhaltet dass dort
darüber nachgedacht ist diese spiele
dann komplett im august stattfinden zu
lassen
und insofern ist nicht davon auszugehen
dass während wir spielen wenn wir denn
dann spielen
und sollten wir im juni oder im juli
waren auch immer die saison beenden ist
nicht davon auszugehen dass wir dass es
da zu terminkollisionen oder termin
koordinierung kommen müsste mit den
europäischen wettbewerben jedenfalls
nicht stand heute dann machen wir weiter
mit alexander hübner von reuters werden
wir haben jetzt in deutschland noch bis
erster september info von
großveranstaltungen klub verdient hat
sogar schon verfügt mit 24 oktober wir
dann tendenziell sagen vom ersten
september geht gar nix oder irgendwie
ebenfalls noch länger zu warten also
vielleicht halten auf die die
bundesliga-trainer viele zuschauer
einfangen aus also ich glaube wie das
momentan auch seitens der
bundesregierung und auch der
ministerpräsident gemanagt wird nämlich
tatsächlich ehren kürzeren etappen zu
planen ist schon der richtige ansatz
insofern machen wir uns aktuell noch
keine gedanken darüber wann könnte denn
die nächste saison starten und wie sie
dann aus sondern wir sind erstmal damit
befasst zu versuchen
die jetzige saison irgendwie zu ende zu
führen
ich hatte glaube ich schon relativ am
anfang dass der debatte wir versuchen
sie also gut wie möglich auch
transparent zu informieren alle paar
wochen ich hatte glaube ich schon ganz
zu anfang gesagt
dass es nicht klug wäre sich darauf
festzulegen dass geisterspiele nicht
mehr stattfinden sollten den
geisterspiele können unter umständen
noch bis ende des jahres stattfinden und
wir wissen nicht ob wir auch im januar
februar märz noch über geisterspiele
sprechen
also insofern haben wir auch innerhalb
der liga und auch mit den klubs bereits
darüber diskutiert dass man durchaus
davon ausgehen sollte mindestens den
ersten teil der nächsten saison die ja
dann theoretisch im august irgendwann
starten würde
und bis dezember reicht also die
vorrunde diesen teil der saison
mindestens zu planen ohne einnahmen aus
zuschauer ohne zuschauer ein was das
dann konkret bedeutet würde man sehen
wenn wir normalerweise in den
spielbetrieb ein staaten könnten
und sowohl medien verträge als auch
sponsoring verträge im weitesten sinne
erfüllt werden können dann hätten die
clubs natürlich durchaus genügend
liquidität zur verfügung in verbindung
und das ist mir schon ganz wichtig mit
vielen anpassungen insbesondere auch was
vereinbarung angeht zum beispiel zur
reduktion von spielergehältern die in
deutschland ja viel schneller vonstatten
ging als in anderen ländern warum woran
das auch immer liegt mit solchen
maßnahmen auf der kostenseite bei klubs
müsste das möglich sein das auch noch
längere zeit zu überbrücken aber nochmal
das ist dann wie es heute ein klub
vertreter aus ausführte wir planen da
irgendwie das bestmögliche
worst-case-szenario spiele ohne
zuschauer möchte keiner möchte kein
fußballfan die möchte auch kein spieler
die möchte auch kein anhänger die
möchten auch keine partner die möchten
auch am wenigsten die die leider nicht
ins stadion können aber für den moment
ist das halt das einzige was wir was wir
ins auge fassen können aber es wäre
völlig vermessen und viel viel zu früh
darüber jetzt zu spekulieren ob jetzt
nach dem 31 oktober oder nach dem 31
august wieder menschen ins stadion
können ich glaube nach wie vor gilt das
was ich vor einigen wochen gesagt habe
deutschland hat immer noch ganz andere
themen
und wir müssen da schon sehr behutsam
und mit augenmaß ran und immer wieder
überprüfen wo wir gerade stehen und ob
das was wir da getan haben noch der
richtige weg ist für die nächsten paar
wochen tut mir später vom city ja hallo
noch mal diesmal die frage der kanzler
dass kinder vorher stand die diskussion
um eine seite des fußballs und sie
hatten ja auch den fehlenden goodwill
von manchen akteuren
fürchten sie dass es klagen aus anderen
sportarten geben könnte wenn der fußball
ist in absehbarer zeit wieder anfangen
dürfte also mit dem fehlenden gut will
meinte ich gar nicht einzelne meine ich
gar nicht spezielle journalisten oder
einzelne kommentare sondern ich stelle
einfach fest dass es offenbar bisher
nicht ausreichend gelungen ist und auch
mal dass nämlich gerne auf meine kappe
nicht ausreichend gelungen ist deutlich
zu machen dass wir deshalb versuchen
müssen zu spielen weil hier einfach eine
institution mit 36 unternehmen
irgendwann wieder beginnen muss zu
arbeiten sonst wird es einfach schwierig
und
die kommentare die sicher teilweise auch
dann auch das konzept beziehen und oder
auf die tatsache dass wir testen und
dass wir menschen tests wegnehmen obwohl
das nach bestem wissen und gewissen und
stand heute einfach nicht der fall ist
trotzdem hält sich dieses hält sich
diese these
die können wir nur versuchen so gut wie
möglich und so aufrichtig wie möglich
der so aufrichtig wie möglich zu
begegnen sagen wir glauben nicht dass
das so ist nach allem was wir wissen
dennoch müssen wir zur kenntnis nehmen
dass diese kommentare eben sehr kritisch
sind und teilweise auch in einem sehr
emotionalen kontext stattfinden und die
tatsache dass die bundesliga vielleicht
wieder spielen darf gleichgesetzt wird
mit anderen lebensbereichen wo dinge
noch nicht möglich sind
das kann ich emotional nachvollziehen
wirklich ich bin ja auch davon betroffen
in meiner familie
ich glaube aber so ein bisschen augenmaß
bei der bewertung würde mich würde mich
schon freuen dass das was wir da tun
nicht anmaßend ist oder überheblich
sondern das wird getan um in dieser
recht schwierigen situation beide liegen
und es geht auch alle klubs da
durchzuführen klagen aus anderen
sportarten kann ich nicht abschätzen
soweit ich das sehe hat sich die
sportministerkonferenz und auch in
einigen
in einigen bundesländern dreht es sich
durchaus ja auch um das thema
berufssport und berufssport ist ja nicht
der profifußball beruf sport sind auch
andere sportarten aber auch da gibt es
eben sehr individuelle rahmenbedingungen
wenn 200 menschen in einem stadion sind
in dem normalerweise 70.000 menschen
sind dann ist es für ganz viele in
diesem stadion möglich abstand zu halten
im freiluft veranstaltungen sind auch
noch mal was anderes als veranstaltung
in geschlossenen räumen insofern ist
glaube ich einfach jede liga oder jedes
unternehmen das bezieht sich nicht nur
auf sport gefordert ein individuelles
medizinisch hygienisches konzept
vorzulegen so wie wir es versucht haben
ob das andere ligen gemacht haben wenn
ja in welcher tiefe wenn ja wie
umfassend kann ich ihnen nicht
beantworten
wir versuchen bestmöglich unseres zu tun
und versuchen auch in der welt des
fußballs eine gewisse solidarität an den
tag zu legen
dann wenn andere ligen zu der
entscheidung kommen für uns taugt das
nichts
wir können es auch gar nicht mehr
umsetzen ohne zuschauer einnahmen gibt
unser gesamtes geschäftsmodell die
medien einnahmen sind so gering für uns
ist egal der der finanzielle schaden ist
so immens dass wir ohne zuschauer gar
nicht spielen können dann ist das so ja
dann hat dann aber nichts mit einer
sonderrolle des fußballs zu tun sondern
einfach mit speziellen situationen in
unterschiedlichen bereichen der
sportindustrie würde ich mal einen
verriss selldorf hat hier unter
terminbedingt verlassen daher hat marc
schmidt von der bild zeitung nun die
letzte frage hallo noch mal in die runde
er sei es gibt ultra gruppierungen die
damit drohen den bundesliga restart
torpedieren zu wollen wenn die
bundesliga also während wieder anfängt
fußball zu spielen haben sie heute in
den videokonferenzen mit den vereinen
noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass es
vielleicht sinnvoll wäre wenn die
vereine auch noch mal in die
kommunikation mit ihren fans gehen
einfach darauf hinweisen dass sie nur so
überleben können ich habe darauf
hingewiesen ja und diese anmerkungen
kamen auch aus reihen der clubs selbst
wie immer im fan dialog muss der erst
mal vor ort stattfinden
fan szenen sind sehr heterogen
strukturiert es gibt ganz individuelle
bedingungen vor ort darüber zu
diskutieren und da auch für überzeugung
zu werben liegt letztlich an den flugs
vor ort ich glaube generell wenn wir
nicht mehr fußball spielen sollen
während der korona krise dann kann das
ziemlich lang sein denn es gibt
unterschiedlichste experten die sagen
das dauert noch mindestens bis mitte
nächsten jahres dann gibt es andere die
sagen das dauert noch zwei jahre
die frage ist ja auch wann ist denn die
krise vorbei wenn es tatsächlich so ist
und auch das sagen ja diverse experten
wir werden lernen müssen mit dem virus
zu leben dann kann das noch eine
ziemlich lange zeit sein und insofern
würde ich mir da bei aller emotionalität
wünschen auch da irgendwie das augenmaß
an den tag zu legen
und ich hoffe dass den klubs vor ort
gelingt mit ihren fans zu ihnen zu
sprechen wenn wir wieder spielen dann
ist ganz klar ein argument dass es nicht
zuschauer ansammlung am stadion kommen
darf
wer das also bewusst in kauf nimmt auch
in kauf dass das spiel stattfindet wenn
wir allerdings im spielbetrieb sein
sollten dann wäre das ein problem dann
wird man sich damit befassen müssen ob
das dann wie abgesprochen wie ein
abgebrochenes spiel zu betrachten ist
und das wird dann eben 2 0 für den
gegner gewertet
aber ich glaube in einer solchen phase
damit zu drohen spiele abzubrechen weiß
ich nicht ob das das richtige mittel der
wahl ist aber ich kann den unmut der da
teilweise zum ausdruck gebracht wurde
über diverse fehlentwicklungen kann ich
inhaltlich manchmal vielleicht sogar
nachvollziehen
und ich hatte gesagt wir werden das
intern besprechen aber für den moment
sind die klubs gefordert mit ihren
jeweiligen fan szenen vor ort in den
dialog zu gehen
vielen dank gesagt hat ich denke damit
sind wir durch vielen dank frau gärtner
vielen dank herr meier fürs kommen
ich hoffe wir haben ihre fragen
beantwortet ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen tag danke schön